body crushing pressure
toxic atmospheres
unbearable temperatures
that's what would be in store for you if
you visited other planets in our solar
system
but what other environmental hazards
would you encounter
which planets would be the safest and
which would be the most dangerous
and how long could you survive on any of
them
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you spent a day on every
planet in our solar system
before you get started on your journey
through the solar system you should pack
a bottle of water earth is the only
planet known to have consistent bodies
of liquid water on its surface so if you
pack enough you could probably survive a
few days just about anywhere right
well sorry to say i've got some bad news
for you
let's start with a visit to mercury the
smallest planet in the solar system
this rocky crater-filled planet is only
slightly larger than our moon and it's
located extremely close to the sun at a
distance of 58 million kilometers
now even though a day on mercury
equals about 59 days on earth your trip
wouldn't last anywhere near that long
due to this slow rotation you could land
on the sunny half where the temperatures
reach
430 degrees celsius
or maybe you'd aim for the dark side
where temperatures drop to minus 180
degrees celsius
your best bet would be to find a cozy
spot somewhere in between
but with an atmosphere mainly composed
of oxygen sodium hydrogen helium and
potassium
good luck breathing for very long
even in this middle ground you wouldn't
likely survive more than two minutes
okay let's check out what a day would be
like on the second planet from the sun
venus
well you should expect a very warm
welcome because surface temperatures are
a piping hot
475 degrees celsius
and one day on venus lasts
243 earth days
and if you want to make this long day
count you could watch all the incredible
documentary series available on magellan
tv
find out what happened in this dead
world with exploring venus
an in-depth look at the possibility of
life on our sister planet
and i have two words for you
cloud creatures
yeah thanks to this documentary i'm
sleeping with one eye open up here
magellan tv has new ad-free titles every
week in hd or 4k
from space science history nature and
physics magellan tv has the most diverse
documentary titles available on any
platform that you can view on any device
claim your special offer at
tribe.magellantv.com
what if right now buy an annual
membership gift card and get another one
for free
explore our universe anywhere anytime
you want
jeez it's
hotted here
unless you've got an impossibly robust
spacecraft you couldn't get very close
to the surface
and even if you did you wouldn't last
very long
venus has a thick and toxic atmosphere
with 154
000 times more carbon than the
atmosphere of earth
and it's shrouded in yellowish clouds of
sulfuric acid
you could say the venusian atmosphere is
a runaway greenhouse effect
between the toxicity and the heat
burning you to a crisp
you wouldn't survive one second on venus
[Music]
now let's skip on over to mars
unless you wanted to stop back on earth
for a couple breaths of fresh air
on mars you'd find comfort in a day that
is a little over 24 hours
what you wouldn't find comfortable is an
atmosphere of carbon dioxide argon
nitrogen and a little bit of oxygen and
water vapor
the surface of mars is cold with an
average temperature of minus 62 degrees
celsius
combine the low surface temperatures
with the unbreathable air and
you wouldn't survive much more than a
few minutes here either
on the next planet you wouldn't be able
to reach the surface
that's because there isn't one on the
gas giant jupiter
this planet is more than twice as
massive as all the other planets in our
solar system combined
and its atmosphere is primarily hydrogen
helium and cold windy clouds of ammonia
and water
jupiter might be bulky but it rotates
fast
one day lasts a mere 10 earth hours and
because it's so fast jupiter's
atmosphere has strong jet streams
plus the great red spot that is actually
a storm bigger than the size of earth
if you fell into the planet you would
enter the atmosphere at a whopping 49
kilometers per second
and as you kept falling the atmosphere
would become denser and more turbulent
you might feel like you were slamming
into a wall again and again
if you made it
692 kilometers down you would find
pressure levels higher than at the
bottom of the mariana trench the deepest
place on earth if the pressure didn't
kill you the temperature which averages
minus
145 degrees celsius certainly would
you wouldn't survive on jupiter for one
second
wow
now if you continued on to saturn you'd
find another gaseous giant without a
surface and like jupiter a day lasts
about 10.7 hours
here you would experience deadly strong
winds reaching up to
1800 kilometers per hour
with an unbreathable atmosphere made of
hydrogen and helium saturn is incapable
of supporting life
maybe you'd have more luck on one of its
moons
like titan or enceladus
these two moons have internal oceans
which could theoretically support life
okay moving on to the first of the ice
giants in our solar system uranus
no surprise here that it also has an
unbreathable atmosphere of hydrogen
helium and methane which gives the
planet its signature blue-green color
and
the stink of rotten eggs
there are some other unusual hazards on
uranus you'd need to be prepared for
such as mysterious flares of x-rays and
all right last but not least neptune
a dark cold planet with supersonic winds
as strong as 2 000 kilometers per hour
that's faster than the top speed of a
fighter jet
so if the pressure didn't kill you those
supersonic winds would probably do the
trick
a day on neptune would last for 16 earth
hours but your life there wouldn't last
a second
okay there it is so in case it isn't
clear
earth would be the only planet you would
want to visit anytime soon
just about anywhere else you could look
forward to a deadly cocktail of high
pressure and toxic gas
i mean that is unless we terraformed
mars
creating a second home for humanity
within the solar system
but
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]